[Music]
House Republicans have proposed a
blueprint for tax reform under which the
United States would adopt a system of
destination based cash flow taxation at
the corporate level what does it mean
for corporate taxation to be destination
based as opposed to origin based it
means that it's the location of the
consumer not of the producer that
determines where the cash flow from a
transaction is taxed but the locations
of consumer and producer often at the
same herein lies the complication if
consumption taxation takes place at the
corporate level as it would under the
house plan and other value-added tax
system one has to then exempt the cash
flow from sales to consumers abroad and
tax the imports purchased by the
domestic consumers from overseas
producers now as long as the u.s. runs a
trade deficit the revenue from taxing
imports exceeds the revenue loss from
not taxing exports and out Republicans
like that which is a blessing reduce
taxes elsewhere and that in a nutshell
it's what border adjustment is to learn
more about my take on border adjustments
check the links in the description below
also let us know what other topics you
want AI scholars to cover in 60 seconds